que ce soit le contour des nuages des
montagnes ou des galaxies de certaines
hallucinations aux formes de légumes
tous ont quelque chose en commun une
beauté singulière un je ne sais quoi
d'envoûtant ce sont toutes des fractales
il existe plusieurs définitions
géométriques compliqué mais retenez
juste pour le moment qu'une forme ou
vous pouvez zoomer à l'infini en
retrouvant la même forme et une fractale
et si je vous disais que derrière ces
fractales et leurs calculs se cache un
secret qui changera le monde
si quantique est un mot à la mode pour
parler des technologies du futur tracta
liste pourrait bientôt inspiré autant
d'engouement
je suis chercheur à l'université en
mathématiques dans le domaine des
fractales et dans mon laboratoire on a
fait des découvertes fascinantes que
j'aimerais justement vous faire
découvrir la nature et l fractale c'est
quand même incroyable que la nature
arrive à produire de tels géométrie
s'isoler de la même manière à toutes les
échelles et dans lesquels on peut
plonger à l'infini grâce au zoom d'un
microscope on s'aperçoit que les flocons
de neige les choux et même vos poumons
sont fatales
certains mathématicien envisage même
sérieusement que l'univers lui-même soit
une sorte de fractal gigantesque pas si
improbable quand on fait l'analogie
entre la structure des amas de galaxies
formées par des système solaire qui
tourne autour d'un trou noir puis on
demande des planètes qui tournent autour
d'une étoile des électrons et c'est
cette valse vertigineuse semble se
répliquer à tous les niveaux mais
pourquoi pourquoi la nature sans bet tel
à gré des structures si complexe qu est
ce qu un brocoli gagne avoir une forme
géométrique dernier cri plutôt qu'une
vulgaire bout le cab aussi le premier de
ces avantages va vous donner le vertige
connaissez-vous un objet dont les
contours sont infinies mais qui puisse
pour autant tenir dans la paume de votre
main pas si facile à imaginer mais
pourtant les fractales ont cette
particularité france a remis ce cube et
retire chacun des petites jupes du
milieu pour créer des trous dans ton
casse tête maintenant divise chaque
petit cube restant en mini cube est
persuadé de la même manière et ainsi de
suite recommence jusqu'à l'infini les
tranches lui plein de trous que tu
obtiens alors les matelas peine mais bon
de menger et croyez le ou non à force de
le percer un rapide calcul montre que
son volume est devenu presque nulle mais
pas sa surface qui elle tend vers
l'infini une fractale c'est ce à
l'infini à portée de main à quoi ça peut
bien servir
regardez par exemple votre portable
comment les agences et des millions de
composants pour qu'il rentre dans un si
petit appareil en et wifi bluetooth
accéléromètre et j'en passe pour ça on
utilise des structure fractale
ça se voyait beaucoup plus sûre des
anciens appareils électroniques vous
reçoit sanguins sont aussi organisés en
fractales des grosses artères qui se
divise en plus petits vaisseaux en z en
capillaire etc
si bien que si on déroule et ouvriers
soit sanguin boutabout leur longueur
ferai deux fois le tour de la terre tout
ça dans votre tout petit corps c'est
juste incroyable
mais vous n'êtes pas au bout de vos
surprises vous avez peut-être déjà
aperçue ce genre d'image psychédélique
ce sont les hallucinations visuelles que
certains consommateurs de l esb peux
voir ton cerveau peut créer des
décisions de fractale en effet sous lsd
les réseaux de neurones du cerveau sont
reconnectées différemment et il se peut
par exemple que le circuit censé réguler
la zone qui s'occupe de la vision soit
dérouté autre part du coup personne
n'est plus là pour signaler au cortex
visuel qu'il a fini son job il se met à
tourner non stop en roue libre perd pied
et réanalyse des trucs qu'il a déjà
analysé ce qui donne l'impression de
plonger dans des images psychédéliques à
n'en plus finir comme une sorte de roll
back un effet devises chez nous où sont
les mathématiques dans tout ça et si je
te dis que la nature a codé des
fractales qui nous entourent façon
matrix à la base du délire ce n'est pas
un matin mais un biologiste
la question qui se pose est peut-on
créer simplement la nature dont la
complexité est infinie c'est vrai
difficile d'étudier un organisme vivant
si on doit se trimballer des structures
presque infini comme nos vaisseaux
sanguins ce biologiste va créer un
codage qui prendra son nom le
système linder meilleur le concept est
archi simple vous prenez deux lettres
par exemple a et b et vous leur
attribuez à chacune des règles par
exemple tous les as se transforme en ab
et tous les bébés se transforme en tout
est prêt il ne reste plus qu'à choisir
un point de départ prenons par exemple
on applique les règles une fois donc à
devient ab puis encore à b devient à b1
est encore à ba2 vient à ba1 à b1 et
s'est très vite ça donne un beau fruit
de l'être mais un fouillis complètement
contrôlé par nos règles de départ c'est
sympa ton truc matin mais ça sert à quoi
en fait la beauté du truc c'est que sans
vraiment s'en apercevoir on vient de
créer un arbre ne croyez pas regardez il
suffit d'afficher les a comme des
branches les baies comme des feuilles et
de modifier légèrement le système avec
d'autres symboles et ta dah et si vous
changez un poil le système de départ
vous pouvez générer ou fougères si vous
préférez d'où vient cette magie si vous
comptez le nombre de lettres à chaque
étape vous apercevez qu'il y en a
exactement la somme des deux étapes
précédentes
à partir de simplement deux lettres et
de règles on est arrivé à coder ce qu'on
appelle la suite de fibonacci
rien de magique juste en suivant nos
règles très simples
la nature a donné naissance à une
fractale la suite de fibonacci d'un
objet mathématique fondamental dans la
nature puisqu'il donne forme aux
spirales de coquillages des galaxies
regardez cette pomme de pain elle est
jolie n'est ce pas essayer de compter le
nombre de spirale bon si vous me dites
12 ou encore 14
bah c'est impossible il y en a forcément
un nombre de la suite de fibonacci
dans ce cas la réponse était 13 est ce
que je vous raconte ne s'arrête pas à la
pomme de pain mais se retrouve chez les
marguerites les choux et j'en passe
fibonacci revient dans de nombreux
concepts lorsqu'on parle du nombre d'or
ou de la théorie du chaos
un exemple avez vous déjà vu le double
pendule du dr nordmann son mouvement est
tellement chaotique on n'arrive pas à le
prédire
eh bien on peut modéliser sa trajectoire
grâce à des fractales même des choses
aussi improbable que la reproduction des
lapins cage des fractales voici
l'équation mathématique de leur
évolution et selon le taux de croissance
que vous allez prendre pour votre suite
en gros si vous là
inquiète beaucoup pas votre population
va évoluer normalement sauf si votre
taux dépasse 3 là les choses deviennent
beaucoup plus intéressante magnifique
fractales n'est ce pas elle n'est pas
seulement belle mais surtout très utile
grâce à ces résultats observés dans la
nature des chercheurs ont par exemple
réussi à mettre en place des appareils
pour soigner des coeurs malades
la chaîne d'irritation m'en parle dans
cette superbe vidéo tout ça pour vous
montrer à quel point les fractales sont
omniprésents dans notre quotidien
comment mesurer l'infini quelle est la
longueur des côtes du royaume uni une
question d'apparence 1 mais qui semble
turlupiner pas mal de spécialistes
on peut essayer de les mesurer sur une
carte mais voici le problème
simon zoom on découvre d'autres replis
qui augmente la longueur et plus on
s'approche plus cette longueur augmente
on peut toujours rajouter le tour d'un
rocher d'un caillou d'un grain de sable
et ça n'en finit plus de s'agrandir vous
l'avez compris le bord de mer est donc
aussi une forme fractales les côtes du
royaume uni ont une longueur infinie
enfin pas tout à fait en pratique
difficile de zoom est plus petit que
l'atome
donc nous irons presque infinies bon on
va pas se mentir cette réponse ne va pas
convaincre grand monde et en plus elle
n'est pas utile du tout puisqu'il n'y a
aucun moyen de comparer la taille des
côtes du royaume uni avec celles de la
norvège
le problème est que la ligne de la côte
est tellement tarabiscoté qu'on dirait
qu'elle est épaisse comme si elle
n'était plus totalement une ligne fine
mais un objet qui commence à avoir une
largeur pas encore une surface mais
assurément plus une ligne infiniment
fine quelque chose entre les deux
regardez c'est plus parlant avec cette
fractale au départ on a bien une ligne
qui n'a pas de largeur juste une
longueur elle est en une dimension mais
quand on commence à l'affairé xavier
avec des va et vient de plus en plus
resserré
elle remplit progressivement le carré
dans lequel on l'a placé jusqu'à
l'occupé complètement on se retrouve à
la fin avec une surface plein en deux
dimensions longueur et largeur pourtant
vous êtes d'accord que ce carré on ne la
remplit qu'avec une ligne un objet inde
et en large en sang selon une forme
fractale
on a donné une surface à un objet qui
n'en avait pas on l'a fait sauter dans
la dimension supérieure
cette courbe n'est donc plus tout à fait
une ligne
tout à fait un plan mais quelque chose
entre les deux on ne peut donc ni
mesurer sa longueur qui est infinie ni
sa surface qui est nul
déroutant nom et le fait que les
fractales puisse avoir des longueurs ou
des surfaces infinie ça soulève pas mal
de problématique
imaginez les mathématiciens à la cantine
qui se mettent à se poser des questions
existentielles du genre puisque le chou
romanesco est une fractale sa surface
est infinie ça veut dire que pour
recouvrir mon assiette j'aurai besoin
d'une quantité infinie de sauce béchamel
un mathématicien outdoor va résoudre ce
problème en introduisant des dimensions
intermédiaire entre les dimensions
entière que nous connaissons n la
longueur dimension un la surface
dimension 2 et le volume dimension 3 il
va expliquer qu'il existe plein d'autres
dimensions non un tiers dimension 1,2 à
1,7 2,99
si vous avez du mal à comprendre à quoi
ça correspond c'est normal disons que ça
indique à quel point un objet à des
replis resserré c'est entre dimensions
permettent ainsi de classer les
fractales selon si elles sont plus ou
moins tarabiscoté pourrait être une
fractale pas besoin d'être auto
similaires il suffit de vivre dans ses
dimensions non un tiers par exemple les
côtes de grande bretagne ont une
dimension fractales d'environ 1,25
quant aux chaudes romanesco sa dimension
fractales est d'environ 2,66 pour vos
poumons dont les alvéoles possède des
multiples recoins pour capter un maximum
des recettes environ 2,9
ces chiffres ne sortent pas de nulle
part vous voulez avoir une idée de
comment les calculs on peut appliquer la
formule de la dimension de outdoor
bon je vous rassure les mathématiciens
eux mêmes galères sur ce calcul car
c'est très abstrait mais du coup ils
préfèrent estimé la dimension de boîte
vous prenez un feutre gris et vous
couriez toutes les cases que touchent
votre fractale ici les côtes de la
grande bretagne puis vous prenez une des
plus fines et vous recommencez à la fin
pour chaque grille vous placer sur ce
graphique le point qui correspond au
nombre de carreaux coloriée en fonction
de la taille des carreaux en riant ces
points vous remarqué que aubin magie ils
sont tous alignés
vous trouverez une belle droite que les
scientifiques adorent car sa pente
indique la dimension fractales de notre
objet tada grâce à ce chiffre
on peut enfin mesurer les fractales sans
tomber sur des résultats absurdes ou
rencontrer l'un finit donc plus besoin
d'une infinité de béchamel pour
recouvrir votre
chou pas de pénurie en vue un futur fait
de fractal six dimensions intermédiaires
sont présentes partout dans la nature
comme on l'a vu ce qui en fait un outil
très puissant puisque on peut
l'appliquer à quasi n'importe quoi
biologie chimie physique et ingénierie
voici comment j'utilise ces calculs au
quotidien dans mes recherches
regardez par exemple ces signaux en
hausse ce sont les battements cardiaques
d'un coureur de marathon surentraînés en
bas ceux d'une personne lambda
à première vue pas vraiment moyen de les
différencier si on vous demandait de
discerner qui est qui vous seriez bien
embêté même pour la x perdre un médecin
il n'y a aucun moyen de les distinguer
tellement les différences sont
imperceptibles est fluctuante aucune
technique d'analysé classiques ne peut
mettre en évidence des caractéristiques
flagrante mais grâce aux fractales tout
devient clair pour chaque portion de la
courbe on peut calculer sa dimension
fractales plus la courbe est irrégulière
en cet endroit plus sa dimension
fractales sera élevé on parle aussi de
rugosité on l'exposera par un nombre
compris entre 0 et 1 si on regarde à
gauche on a par exemple représenté en
rouge des proportions très rugueuse et
anvers à droite des proportions plus
régulière ces deux ensembles de poing
forme des fractales différentes pour que
ça soit lisible on n'a qu'à regrouper
les points de même couleur qui partagent
la même rugosité cuite calculer sa
dimension fractales comme on l'a vu
précédemment quand on effectue ce
classement on obtient une belle courbe
qui nous montre de quelle façon la
courbe et fractale on appelle ça le
spectre multi fractales une sorte de
carte d'identité
maintenant la différence entre le
marathonien et le nom sportif est
carrément plus flagrante sur ce spectre
on va pouvoir déceler des
caractéristiques auparavant invisibles
l'intérêt de toutes les recherches est
de savoir ce qu'il se passe dans le
coeur d'un coureur lorsque celui-ci
s'entraîne ou encore mieux savoir
détecter des pathologies cardiaques avec
une grande précision grâce à un simple
enregistrement
lorsqu on s'est rendu compte de ça on a
direct eu l'idée d'utiliser dans l'art
et ceux qui n'étaient pas visibles à
l'oeil nu sur des tableaux de biens
obvious sur leurs spectres fractales par
rapport aux toiles de maîtres toutes les
répliques même les copies les plus
fidèles ont un spectre décaler vers la
droite qu'il crut les mathématiques ont
trouvé un moyen de démasquer les faux en
art et ce n'est que le début
à chaque nouveau signal analysé
découvre de nouvelles caractéristiques
caché en finance en urbanisme en
médecine et bien d'autres encore
l'analyse multi fractales est un outil
dont on commence à peine à percevoir les
possibilités j'espère vous avoir
transmis un peu de mon enthousiasme et
avoir cassé quelques idées reçues sur la
recherche mathématique car ce n'est pas
juste d'être assis devant des équations
incompréhensible et attendre d'avoir une
idée c'est de la création des moments
d'excitation des tâtonnements des
déceptions des collaborations bref toute
une aventure dans mes journées je lis
des livres très spécialisés ou des
articles pointus son sujet je calcule
tests mes théories et mes idées pour
espérer atteindre un gros résultat
de fait des simulations pour illustrer
et je regarde c'est ce que j'ai trouvé
s'applique à d'autres domaines
et enfin je discute il échange avec
d'autres chercheurs pour en apprendre
plus et aller encore plus loin que ce
soit lors d'une réunion ou lors de
conférences
l'objectif final est de pouvoir rédiger
un article propre rigoureux et riche en
contenu pour pouvoir le soumettre dans
une revue qui permettra aux chercheurs
qui la liront d'utiliser ses résultats
pour avancer dans leurs propres
recherches et repousser encore les
limites de nos connaissances
car on l'oublié avec tous les prix qu'on
donne mais la recherche n'est pas le
fruit d'une personne mais d'une lignée
de chercheurs du plus modestes aux plus
illustres
j'espère que cette vidéo très personnel
vous a plu si vous voulez en savoir plus
n'hésitez pas à aller voir mon site
internet ou à lire des articles je parle
entre autres de mes recherches sur les
séries aléatoire d'anglet où vous pouvez
aussi me suivre directement sur twitter
ou instagram
c'était guillaume cesse alias matar et
des d'antoine et de pleins d'amis
mathématicien je vous dis à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui